i work at buzzfeed and i had my lunch
stolen my lunch
was stolen not only have i heard of this
lunch bandit
but i'm a victim they got me i'm
detective tobach
and i'm gonna get to the bottom of this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so here's what's happening
here at buzzfeed we have a lovely
community of people the offices are
great everyone feels safe coming in but
recently
someone's been stealing the lunches from
our fridges this is not the office i
remember
so i'm gonna fix it i'm gonna find this
person and i'm gonna
tell him to to like stop taking lunches
i'm like i'm gonna ask him because
that's not cool so what happened was
that
um i got a sandwich it was completely
untouched it was wrapped in foil
so i put the creamy caesar salad in the
fridge that's done set my calendar
invite pick up your salad at 4
30 because like y'all could not forget
it because i'll be pissing myself if i'm
on train and i'll have my damn salad
i had eaten halal cart i had purposely
eaten only half
i covered the rest in tin foil i put my
name on it check c-h-a-c-k
and the date 12-3 two hours later when i
went back to check on it
it was gone my salad's not there they're
gone these
these leftovers are gone and it just i
knew instantly it was like
somebody stole my lunch it's one of the
most [ __ ] up things i've ever seen in
my life
it was like 4 p.m like this is 4 30. the
day's not even over
how bold does your ass have to be to
take my salad and it's not even 6 p.m
i'm pissed i'm so pissed i'm so bad
there was one lunch stolen
and everyone on the floor was alerted
that the lunch was stolen
and then not 15 minutes later another
lunch was stolen
from right out under our little noses
one wasn't enough they went for two this
person won't stop until they're caught
and they will be caught by me
who could it be i would be shocked if
this isn't you
eric has multiple lunches every day
on any given day you can walk over to
eric's desk
pull open his bottom drawer and see this
huge stash of snacks that he
has just been collecting for months i'm
on your team
and i know that you're a video short
this month this could all just be for
that extra video
okay now i really need to figure out who
this person is so i can prove it's not
me
what can i do um i could be a
refrigerator bouncer and i can write
everything down and i'll know if
somebody's taking out something they
didn't put in
that'll probably freak out the thief so
that's not gonna work oh maybe i could
be like a far away
refrigerator bouncer but then i'm not
gonna be able to see anything so
that's not gonna work what if i what if
i talk to security and and they could
show me the security footage but
i don't wanna get security involved just
yet oh my god i could do like gps track
food so i could put a gps and then i
could make a gourmet dish and then i
could wrap it up
and i could put it in the fridge and
wait for it but what if it doesn't get
stolen
[Music]
great five more people had their lunch
stolen i have to actually do something
about this
i'm gonna talk to more people everybody
in the office was talking about it and
after asking a bunch of people who they
thought it was
two names popped up to be honest i kind
of think it was clark
just because i've never seen him buy
lunch i think it's victor
he's too he's too happy too i can't
trust the person who's always happy
it was definitely clark because he's a
sneaky little [ __ ]
i think it's vick he is always in the
kitchen
he has easy access i decided to
interview my two suspects
clark and vic you haven't heard anything
that's happening on the 16th floor
no basically someone has been stealing
food from the refrigerator leftover food
that's been labeled
there is there's some drama that got
pretty violent i think
last year we had this beloved giant
toy called rastafrog and he went missing
and nobody could find him
five days later we find him in a
dumpster outside a buzzfeed with his
throat slit
i have no idea what clark is talking
about so
i'm just gonna move on what's going on
um
so i don't know if you know this but
someone's been stealing food from the
refrigerators
i am actually a villain
i am not the most pretty
but no i am a victim of the lunge bird
i don't know what to do with any of this
information i need to take this to the
top
i decided to meet with a private
investigator his office was very
intimidating he had statues of himself
pictures of himself pictures of him with
famous people and more famous people
i thought i was just meeting with a
regular private investigator i didn't
realize i was meeting with
the private investigator
oh boy thank you for doing this by the
way thank you for meeting with me i
didn't even know who the [ __ ] i was
i know i didn't i mean where'd you wake
up in a [ __ ] pumpkin patch or
something
i i actually i don't know private
investigators forget about private
events
i was a new york city homicide detective
son here
see these dead people here all shot in
the head pen dead the palm sunday mascot
son you got to do a little due diligence
before you come talk to the man
yeah what i'm shooting like that right
now no no i have a
dead shot in the head right so i'm i'm
only getting into investigation now this
is my first investigation ever
so in our office we have had somebody
steal food from the public refrigerator
so we have
we have a community fridge just like
every office and
somebody's been taking the food it's you
clean it out normally
it's only cleaned down on fridays but
people are losing their food every
single day now
that i mean they actually get rid of
everything everybody yeah because that
smells after yes yes yeah yeah it smells
like dead body but it's missing
not on fridays like new food somebody
got salad and somebody took the salad
out of the box
you know you got the top detective in
the world
and we're asking about salad being
stolen out of a friggin refrigerator
it's it's a big it's become a big issue
in the office
oh it's big but how big is it really i
hope it's not romaine salad it's still
deadly then
we could place romaine in the fridge
whoever takes the romaine then they'll
be themselves and we'll catch them
well i'm going to give you a little
secret yes look up there
huh up there where
the planes so if that ain't that [ __ ]
camera don't jump out here
oh my gosh i'm allowed to just set up
again yes you can
the law of new york state each state is
different two-party consent
new york state is a one-party consent
right now you're recording me i know
you're recording me
that's perfectly legal and even if you
wore a
tape recorder on you without these
cameras and you talked to me
and recorded me perfectly legal some
states it's not
you have to have the other person's
consent new yorkers it's a one-party
state
once i figure it out i just scare them
so they stop doing it no i would
question them
straight out were you taking that salad
out of that refrigerator
were you hungry what was the reason
you know because some people are hurt
some people are on a diet they're going
to eat salad
and maybe that's their only means of
energy
and nutrients and they're stealing the
thing amazing thank you so much
that's it that's it oh my gosh so you
call upon
the top detective in the world
they ask him about salad in the
refrigerator i now knew how to private
investigate a situation
so i went back to the office i set up a
camera facing the refrigerator
and i watched
after three and a half hours i saw
the refrigerator thief steal my friend's
sandwich
so i messaged him to meet in a private
room i walked over
i planned to record the entire
conversation on my iphone
and this is the audio hey what's up
um thanks uh thanks for
sorry i just had it i just wanted to ask
you real quick i think um
i think i saw you like stealing a lunch
what what are you talking about
did you did you take someone's lunch
today by any chance no
they take someone's lunch what are you
talking about
oh okay my no yeah my bad i don't know
i'm no
jimmy confused with somebody else maybe
i'm sorry no no my bad
you're good you sure yeah okay
all right i'm gonna do that thanks
thanks for coming in
have a happy day have a good day
i definitely that was definitely the guy
i just felt like
way too uncomfortable i'm not an actual
detective i
obviously i couldn't do it i couldn't
but it was it was definitely him
was it him i decided to go back and
re-watch the surveillance footage
it was him but he wasn't the only one
i realized there was no cereal lunch
thief
i couldn't believe it anybody
could steal a lunch everybody in the
world eats food
everybody that means it could be your
family member
your lover these people in this stock
footage
[Music]
christian was right it could be me
it could be you
you